entre estos edificios de los suburbios
parisinos se encuentra un pequeño
paraíso verde con 72 árboles y sin
asfalto en el suelo aquí cuando hay
altas temperaturas se está mucho más
fresco que a pocos metros en el horno de
la ciudad
que dice aprista obra ya que es
agradable hay más árboles más aire
realmente lo cambia todo sales porque el
suelo negro del exterior atrae demasiado
el sol y aumenta el calor es bonito es
un espacio donde comemos a mediodía
estamos a la sombra hay un poco de aire
hay una clara sensación de frescura el
arquitecto andrés wernick es uno de los
artífices de este espacio verde urbano
se necesitaron tres años de trabajo para
reinventar completamente el lugar como
cuando empezamos aquí había un
estacionamiento de 50 plazas totalmente
asfaltados negro y en relativamente mal
estado nada para los peatones y esto es
lo que hicimos un tipo de bosque y al
mismo tiempo un espacio público urbano
de los 1000 metros cuadrados la
concentración de árboles crea una sombra
que refresca inmediatamente pero también
permite provocar un fenómeno
característico de las plantas la
evapotranspiración de los árboles
extraen el agua del suelo y la hacen
transpirar a través de sus ojos eso
reduce la temperatura del aire así que
los árboles en una especie de
infraestructura de enfriamiento en la
ciudad gratuita así que no plantamos
estos árboles tanto por razones
estéticas sino por razones de
enfriamiento
para que los árboles transpiren
correctamente deben recibir agua el
suelo es poroso para que el agua de la
lluvia pueda filtrarse y bajar
directamente a las raíces
no queda nada en la superficie no
importa cuánta agua añada gracias a
estos instrumentos el proyecto es
supervisado científicamente el resultado
es un descenso de la temperatura de 2.5
grados en promedio y hasta 6 grados
durante los picos de calor en los
últimos años paris ha sufrido intensas
olas de calor según el servicio
meteorológico francés si no se hace nada
podría haber entre 10 y 25 veces más
para el año 2050 las grandes ciudades
son las más afectadas por el
calentamiento global que se debe en
parte a la actividad humana como los
motores y el aire acondicionado pero
también a la arquitectura urbana se
citan que dio más detalles y no fue quad
un cañón urbano es una calle estrecha
rodeada de edificios altos
normalmente en parís hay muchas calles
así que son muy minerales así que no hay
vegetación ni agua por lo tanto el poder
de enfriamiento de esta vegetación y del
agua falta y las superficies minerales
almacenan el calor y los liberan por la
noche lo que dificulta que la ciudad se
enfríe
efecto alguien anima la soja falla por
ello una de las prioridades de los
municipios es transformar las zonas
asfaltadas
especialmente un área le interesa a
parís los patios de recreo de los
colegios repartidos por toda la ciudad
representan más de 70 hectáreas
tradicionalmente cubierto de asfalto son
importantes depósitos de calor como aquí
en el distrito 19
7 conforme
se construye en los años 90 es un patio
muy abierto al sol poco sombreado muy
mineral así que el proyecto es crear
sombra podemos ver que es muy escasa en
este periodo soleado acabamos hoyos para
los árboles toda esta zona estaba
cubierta de hormigón y asfalto
se están renovando 25 patios en la
capital y ya se han transformado 46 como
en este jardín infantil
tú tdt de víctima se quitó todo el
asfalto las virutas de madera se colocan
y sustituyen regularmente y aquí
llegamos a la parte muy muy verde el
huerto ahí tenemos calabacines tomates
un poco más allá estos patios de recreo
llamados oasis no sólo benefician a los
niños de la escuela
sino también a los residentes del barrio
todos los sábados este patio está
abierto a los habitantes que deseen
venir a disfrutar de un espacio de
naturaleza de sombra para poder pasear
leer jugar con sus hijos
para completar este arsenal contra el
calor las ciudades también apuestan por
el efecto refrescante del agua
la alcaldía de parís acaba de instalar
estos nebulizadores
esta es una de las 31 fuentes
nebulizadores una fuente 2 en 11 puede
beber del grifo y también tiene un
nebulizador para refrescarse además
tenemos 1200 fuentes de agua potable así
que la red es bastante amplia con este
dispositivo añadimos una función de
enfriamiento para adaptarnos al cambio
climático y a las olas de calor la
creación de estas islas de press cura se
ha convertido en una cuestión crucial la
capital ya superó los 2 grados de
calentamiento con respecto a la era
preindustrial a finales de siglo las
principales ciudades podrían
experimentar un aumento de la
temperatura de 8 grados